David Cameron do you know how many food
banks there were in this country when
you came to power I don't have the exact
figures but I know that usage of food
banks has gone up and there are many
amazing volunteers humane those be banks
and provide an important service there
was 66 when you came to power there are
now 421 900 thousand people took food
parcels last year free food parcels you
talked about broken Britain and fixing
it you haven't is more broken now than
it was I don't accept that because if
you look at what's happened we are a
khazi there are 1.8 9 million more
people in work than when I became Prime
Minister we've got 900 thousand fewer
people on activist and a freeze in food
banks a mark of success of obviously
there has been an increase in food bank
use that's partly because of the
difficulties we face as a country it's
also Jeremy because we changed the rules
the previous government didn't allow job
centers to advertise the existence of
food banks they thought it would be bad
PR I thought that was a wrong decision I
thought it was a poor decision so we
allowed them to point people towards
food banks if they needed them but look
the big picture is here is we want to
get more people back to work we've
turned the economy around and its jobs
are the best route it's acceptable in a
rich country like ours that there are
that number of people depending on free
food aid obviously I want fewer people
to be using food banks and I want more
people to have the security of a job but
we have created a thousand jobs for
every day this government's been in
office now that's a statistic but behind
that statistic are people who are able
to provide for their families who are
earning a wage who are able to build a
better life